hello
and welcome i'm anita wood the program
manager for the stanford
energy innovation and emerging
technologies program
also known as the e-i-e-t program
on behalf of the stanford center for
professional development and the
stanford bits and watts initiative
which is in the stanford pre-court
institute for energy i would like to
welcome you
to this special session on the
transformation of the electric grid
with dr rahm raja kapal rahm is an
associate professor
of civil and environmental engineering
and a senior fellow
at the stanford pre-court institute for
energy dr
rajic paul teaches the e-i-e-t-237
transforming the grid course in the
stanford eiet program
he directs the stanford sustainable
systems lab which is focused on
large-scale monitoring
data analytics and stochastic control
for infrastructure networks
in particular power networks and his
current research
interests in power systems are in the
integration of renewables
smart distribution systems and demand
side data analytics
for this session he will be talking
about looking beyond technical
considerations
and integrating distributed energy
resources
he will also talk about cyber
constraints privacy
and energy equity rom's presentation
will be followed by
several pre-recorded questions and
answers
now let's begin first of all thank you
for
hosting our session just here on the
left hand side of this very first slide
i chose a picture of something that is
hot off our research to show the power
of open data
we have been able to analyze the demand
hourly demand
from 58 countries around the world to
understand
the impact of covid 19 restrictions on
the demand and you can see here
this work was entirely done by a group
of students
and postdocs i thought a little bit
about what is interesting
today and kind of the title of the
presentation reflects that
at stanford what is our some of our key
interests
these are the concepts i have here
virtualization
learning coordination and privacy slash
fairness
in these consumer driven distributed
energy systems
this is very important because the word
consumer here
means there is people and their
preferences
that need to be taken into account so i
think that's a major
distinction of the traditional view of
such systems
you know we all are familiar with the
grid i'm just going to go very quickly
here
and the traditional grid is changing
because we have
massive adoption of renewables and new
technologies such as storage
at the transmission level but at the
same time
behind the meter consumers are adopting
new technologies as well
like ev charging smart appliances
self-generation through solar pv for
example
and all of these technologies are
connected to the cloud
this enables us to
collect data and send signals and
potentially coordinate all these
resources
to achieve individual and joint goals
that can serve you know to the wholesale
market so you can have flexible
load that follows generation instead of
the other way around
but also as we start to see of
increased adoption of these technologies
this
coordination can be used to mitigate the
impacts on the distribution network
so one of the research focuses here
in stanford has really been around
how do we utilize
this capability behind the meter
to support the rest of the grid
ecosystem
and when we say that what are the key
challenges here
the first one is that we need to
understand
what is the real flexibility available
at each customer and that critically
depends
not just on the technologies they have
but also their preferences
how much are they willing to change
adapt and adjust
and learning that at the scale that
needs to be done
is something that still remains
extremely challenging and an open
question
and something that i feel for example
you need
not just methods but a lot of open data
interaction with customers and so on the
second question is well if we know the
consumer preferences
and assuming we have a model for the
distribution network
then we can start to think about how to
scale this coordination
to millions of heterogeneous resources
again the key word here is scaling
there is many many strategies and
architectures for coordination
this is very well known but do they
actually scale
to the scale we need them to go the
third one
i think is very critical and goes into
the economics and policy because
it is all about whatever strategies you
create whatever platforms
ideas etc be it to collect data or to
coordinate
you definitely need to make it easy and
attractive
for consumers to engage that means not
asking them tons of questions
you know or are asking a lot of effort
on their part
and also mechanisms to compensate them
last but not least i think we're seeing
a dramatic
change in society today regarding two
ideas
and i think it's time we took them more
deeply
into how we design these energy systems
particularly consumer driven ones
[Music]
that took care of the data was just the
utility
so the privacy was in a way managed by
utility regulators but now we're talking
about aggregators
different types of service providers and
so on
we need a broader and expanded
definition of what privacy is and
actually ways to enforce it
monitor it measure it and the second
topic i think is one of fairness
so i will address those briefly at the
end of the presentation
what we mean by fairness is we need to
give
both equal access to the participation
in these modern systems but we also need
ways to ensure that the systems we
create
don't exploit particularly vulnerable
customers so you know families who have
lots of people who stay home
tend to be lower income and maybe your
demand response algorithm
would continuously target them for
turning on and off
these are considerations that have been
taken into account in economics and
more now on web search and things like
that but
i think there's a whole open question
about how to do this from a technical
perspective
but also institutionally how utilities
and companies aggregators
technology providers policy makers are
going to deal with these issues
i just wanted to kick off the
conversation with something that we did
recently which is kind of unusual
here for our group we worked with a
sociologist and a psychologist to try to
understand
in a real population how much actual
consumer flexibility there is
on their loads and devices that you see
and in this graph here what you see is
really
what percentage of each one of these
activities is performed during the peak
time
this was a population of 370
individuals and the paper came out in
energy policy around this
and you can see here for example tvs
watched 90
during the peak time etc and in black
that's kind of the willingness to shift
what percentage of people were willing
to shift
and you can see that just very few items
like your washer dryer dishwasher
are things that both meet
somewhat being used in the peak time and
somewhat willing to shift
so this started shaping a lot of our
groups thinking on how to design the
systems that respond to this
need and i'll address that when we talk
a little bit about powernet
but i think this kind of engagement and
interaction with
consumers now they're doing a project
where we educate
these households through their kids to
understand their own consumption from
smart meter data
and then try to execute on the shift
it's a little bit
away from the traditional path but it's
all about
how do you have this human in the loop
during
this kind of management and it's a ton
of work and very interesting as well
so if you come here in the summer we
have workshops with
you know hundreds of kids and it's super
exciting
okay going more towards learning
you know the first idea i feel is very
critical
is that in economics there's a gold
standard about how you learn preferences
you usually say people have a utility
function
i'm going to show them different choices
observe the choice they make
and then model this utility function
that is kind of the embedded value of
the choice
and there is lots of techniques for that
and it's well known
this typically translates in the utility
world of
electric utilities as we will do
randomized trials on different programs
that we have let's say for demand
response
to understand the size of the effect and
then model the heterogeneity of that
effect
as a function of customer
characteristics collected from
questionnaires
it turns out that these models in the
electricity side
perform not so great typically if you
you created models like this and we work
closely for example with pg e on looking
at this
and then you say now i want to recruit
enough customers to have a megawatt
of demand response on this particular
feeder
you end up with something like 10 to 20
percent of that that's kind of it called
the yield
just as a point of comparison you know
if you go and talk to somebody at amazon
they will say that these offers that are
put
on your first landing page of the amazon
website when you see it
75 of the people click on one of those
offers
and then of those clicks between 50 to
70 percent of the people actually
purchased what they saw
so that is overall much more than
like a demand response offer where
you're actually offering money to the
customer
and yet the engagement is less
economists looked at these questions
in the last 10 years and there's a
really beautiful stream of literature on
that
and what they kind of found is that this
is called the issue with
stated preferences because normally we
are not able to observe what
actions customers take with regards to
their electricity consumption
so you do polls and surveys like the one
i had before
and then use those polls and surveys to
predict how much flexibility customers
have and that goes directly into the
planning
and so those predictions don't
completely capture
the preferences because customers don't
pay a lot of attention to their
electricity bill it's not a big part of
their budget
so this is an issue not just with
electricity in many other areas
declared preferences of things that
won't don't weigh on your pocket as much
are not accurate so one idea that we
developed
in partnership with pg ese and
a host of utilities was this idea that
well
i have a smart meter that's like high
resolution temporal data
that data it's like an mri of
customers preferences if i could
interpret that
mri and by that here is what i mean
extract features
like what's the peak load base load
what's the thermal sensitivity
what are the load shapes i can use these
features
to build these models for segmentation
targeting etc
this gave rise a project called wisdom
which was carried out here at stanford
from 2011
to 2016 and then we released this
open source package called wisdom it's
now
used in eight u.s utilities in southern
california edison pg e
vermont etc and then a few more
worldwide
and it's completely free open source you
can download and
i think in 2016 when we released it we
had analyzed about 8 million
smart meters with this package since
then you know we haven't
uh really kept track of what's going on
so just as an
initial like the very first result from
wisdom is shown here
we just did the first study ever at the
time
at the scale that was done which was
66 million customer days we looked at 66
million customer days across the bay
area
and performed clustering and when we
started doing this study pg e gave us
the data
that took itself like a year or two and
then when we did the study initially
the consensus was well why should we do
this
it's well known in planning that all
customers
are this dual peak shape and then when
we actually did the clustering
we found many different load shapes for
each day including just consuming at
night
very flat consumption evening peaks
and the so-called planning option
it's only fourteen percent of the load
shapes and this is very critical
because for example load shape number
811 here
actually can have demand response
capability at 3 pm
versus this guy here 14 can have
no such significant capability so
first lesson from this project is
when you're thinking about these new
kinds of flexibility that are emerging
number one due to the preferences of
consumers the flexibility may or may not
be there
like you saw from the survey number two
data and massive data are essential to
have
accurate models of consumer preferences
to achieve the types of performance we
need to make these things
cost effective for the future so the
second question we had in our list
up there was okay so we understand
customer preferences
maybe we can collect a few of these
consumers
and use their capabilities to offer
services back to the grid
or to reduce their bill or something
like that
how do we do that at scale that was the
genesis of this project powernet
it's a project that has been funded by
the california energy commission
and arpaio as part of the nodes program
and we had as partners
zodian suntech drive and google google
also funded the project and it's also a
partner
of the technology and it started out
with a simple
kind of interesting observation at the
time we
started this project in my group
and in abbas el gamal he's another
faculty here at stanford
in his group we had had a few
collaborations around
optimization algorithms for storage and
kind of distributed control and this is
kind of a big fad in power systems
and these algorithms work great in
matlab
and that means in simulation and then
you know i
visited google and arun majumdar's
former group the one that he created
because i had this kind of question that
was put forward by
my student gustavo well but how do we
know these algorithms actually work in
the real world
and then somebody told me arun was doing
this in google and we went and visited
that group
and what they had tried was actually to
implement
in a lab scale with realistic
constraints
in terms of the cyber constraints the
information exchange constraints
several of these algorithmic strategies
and what they found out
is that fully distributed algorithms
although
very elegant and beautiful theoretically
they don't really scale well and it's
very hard to diagnose
it's very expensive to try to set them
up with customers and so on
and in fact at that time they had just
managed to do like
one home and technologies inside it and
tried to coordinate the energy
consumption
and they had done a survey with
customers because they needed to collect
preferences
and google does these user surveys and
they said well
we're going to collect your preferences
and here's our idea we're going to put
forward a questionnaire
with 50 questions that you need to
answer so we know
everything we need to know about how you
like your house to be like your
temperature set point and so on so forth
and the result of the survey was that
the immense majority of people
said they would never use a system like
that i just thought about my
own home there is the three preferences
for the thermostat set point and nobody
can really agree on it so
that's an example of you know trying to
do that 50 times
is impossible we decided when we went to
look at nodes
we wanted to propose a project which was
about building
a real system that can do such
coordination
which addresses the scaling issue
and that means really addressing three
critical problems at the same time
one problem is whatever coordination
mechanism you create
it coordination is going to happen also
through the power network in our case
here we focus on the distribution
network
the second is whatever mechanism you
create
needs to learn and understand consumer
preferences
in our case we picked the consumer to be
homes
initially the preferences of the
homeowner have to be taken into account
into the coordination
the idea of picking up homes was also
because each home by itself cannot
really provide much value
back to the grid but in coordination
they can do a lot
and the third issue is that whatever
scheme you create or architecture or
solution you create
needs to be able to account for the real
constraints out there in terms of
information exchange
so data exchange and communications and
so on
we spotted at the time this notion of
well we can use the cloud to do
coordination
and for example this is already done in
data centers so the cloud
runs the coordination of the
communication between the server racks
but the key idea even in the data center
case
is the cloud cannot do this in real time
because whenever you put the cloud in a
feedback loop there is delays
on the information exchange there's
reliability issues if you try to make it
geographically spread
and this is all stuff we learned from
google so how do you do it
so that the cloud is not really at every
second
and every minute calculating and sending
the decisions
to all the homes so that was this origin
of this project powernet
here's how the system that we came up
with
was laid out and again we started this
project
in kind of an unusual way because we
decided to build a lab in stanford
put these devices and things together
work with google connect everything to
the cloud etc without knowing
what the solution was going to be and we
experimented with tons of algorithms
until we figured something that worked
and that also had some theoretical
justification
but that is still kind of work in
progress the theory around this
the key idea of the system is that every
home
has a smart hub a local intelligence
it's a computing
capability that communicates
digitally with you know your inverters
for the solar panel
storage or ev chargers and also with
this
smart dimmer this is a new kind of smart
panel
that was designed by our colleague
professor
juan rivas working with students this
panel allows you to have high resolution
measurements
of all of the sub-circuits of the home
but also
the capability to do voltage control
at the sub-circuit level so you can have
some controllability of
loads appliances and so on even without
actually the appliance being smart
necessarily
so that's kind of the resources you have
and normally this home would have a bill
and it tries to minimize the bill
using data and these resources but in
order to minimize the bill
and also to do coordination which is
homes might get together and say well
let's shave the peak in this transformer
because we'll get some compensation from
the hotend market or maybe directly from
the utilities and from the demand
response program
in order to do all of that they do need
to understand and account for the impact
they will have
on transformer capacities and network
voltages
so that's kind of the setting and
how did we solve this i'm not going to
enter into a lot of details
but i'll go a little bit into this
project first
it required thinking about this
architecture
of how does the local controllers and
this kind of cloud coordinator
engage and we also imposed ourselves
this issue that we want to minimize the
information exchange and the cloud
cannot run in real time
and so what we found is an architecture
that has
a planning stage that's run every 24
hours
in alignment with the day ahead market
and in that planning stage
it sends these dynamic
power bounds so it's like uh
establishing
a bandwidth for each one of the homes
in terms of each hour how much power are
they allowed to draw
or inject back into the grid so instead
of having a static bound given by the
transformer
they can have a dynamic bound and it
turns out if you do these calculations
cleverly this is enough to really
protect the network
while enabling the coordination we
designed this uh smart dimmer
we also did lots of algorithms with data
from
predictions to learning the customer
preferences from observing their choices
and using appliances
and then the biggest effort in the
project was a massive kind of deployment
so we had
a large-scale lab that was kind of built
between stanford and slack
then we have deployments in a real world
farm
and 20 homes in fremont where we put
you know battery storage solar we read
their data
we kind of do all kinds of things i'm
just gonna
uh point out one thing here and then
move on
you know the critical challenge on the
coordination is that there is a spatial
and temporal data asymmetry it has not
to do just with the technical issues
it's because who knows what information
the utility knows the network
but doesn't necessarily have access to
behind and later devices
dr providers have access to their own
devices
but no information on the overall load
or the utility network
and so on so how do you deal with this
data asymmetry
and so the design of powernet addresses
this issue
by figuring out how the information
needs to be shared
and how that shared information is
utilized so that
we can maximize the benefits for
the consumers their actual participants
in these systems
we initially when we designed this
system
one of the things that we learned and i
think this is kind of
the first major lesson is seeking this
kind of
elusive optimality that you see when you
design algorithms and you test them in
simulations
it's actually detrimental in
designing real scalable solutions what
we found is by sacrificing some of that
optimality
you can really take into account all of
these practical constraints and achieve
good results
so you can reduce the voltage deviations
that would result from
people synchronizing all their decisions
you can also do things like
offer ramping services regulation
services we showed all of those
and then if you look at the end of the
month into their bill
you know you still achieve like 90
percent
of the ideal oracle reduction so they
can't even achieve that in practice
but just that small sacrifice results in
big
here's kind of the lab that we built and
you can see this is a lab that was a
partnership between industry
the stanford school of engineering and
our pae so
in industry the engagement was through
this bits and watts program
that liang directs and you can see here
we have like
a smart home with real appliances it's
connected to a panel it's connected to a
solar panel
to a battery system water heater the
whole thing
and to an ev charger this home is
connected to a home that's a little bit
more virtual
and here's like a grid emulator all of
this system is connected to
something like 10 000 virtual homes
in gridlab d and open dss now
this whole lab is connected to a similar
lab in slack that had more of larger
loads
and were meant to emulate small and
medium businesses
and this is where we initially tried to
design our solutions and demonstrate
them
and we learned so much from first of all
interoperability yes we do have the
sunspec alliance
but if you try to go and read any
information from real inverters
it doesn't really work we did the field
tests
and we have successfully deployed this
system in a farm
and then now we are doing it in homes in
fremont you can see here
the cooling of cows in this real dairy
facility
is one of the largest dairy facilities
in the united states
and they spend about 200 000 every
summer
with this cooling and what we are able
to show is that using powernet you can
reduce about 50
of that cost and what powernet does is
it coordinates
storage the solar panels on the rooftop
of the barns
and the fan control and tries to
maintain the cow temperatures
appropriately right now using airflow
measurements but we have installed like
a
thermal camera so as you can see in the
system i use this as an example because
there's a lot of embedding of iot
solutions from different vendors and so
on
i'm just going to wrap up with our
latest project so after we did powernet
we realized
there are a lot of principles on how you
should design
the software solution for this and the
architecture
and we wanted to look into how to do
this at an even larger scale and we
partnered up with
folks in computer systems design here at
stanford
and decided to look into this issue of
virtualization modularity and layering
which is
their principles of how they do computer
systems design
and that gave source to this project
called trustdr
the goal is to ensure resource
virtualization
security and privacy for all of these
algorithms
by virtualization it's a simple concept
can you take
one resource and make it look like many
virtual resources
or many resources and looking as one
from a software perspective so
then you write your solutions you don't
have to worry about this
and then in the privacy and fairness
it's all about
really protecting the privacy of the
customer if i have to have data privacy
how do i design
algorithms it turns out to be pretty
difficult to do that
to conclude i just wanted to leave the
form of engagement
we have had through all these projects
is using this affiliate model for
partnerships through the bits and what's
program
we work very closely with companies
gathering their inputs
having them participate in board of
advisors and in some cases directly join
our research teams and students who
finish these projects sometimes go on to
develop these technologies commercially
sometimes they go into these companies
as employees
and so on so forth i also have a
flagship program that was started
through this partnership
around evs thank you very much thank you
ron for sharing with us some of your
work
we have a few questions that were
submitted the first question is high
level
then we'll dig a little deeper to start
would you take a few minutes to explain
how der measures
and grid digitalization affect grid
resilience
in terms of the resiliency i think there
is
two key ideas one is understanding
how do you translate consumer
flexibility into resiliency
because what is resiliency how do you
measure it for example
if i have an earthquake in san mateo it
will affect the homes
it might disrupt some of the solar pv it
might
affect part of the grid what do i mean
by
being resilient do i have to provide
full power to the remaining homes
or is it part power does it depend on
the intensity of the event
we collaborated with the faculty who
does earthquake
engineering to try to define these
metrics
around the ers and it turns out there's
two key aspects in my mind
one is you need to understand
something like what is the full load
potential half load potential
no load potential of each customer the
second one
i think it's it's a lot harder which is
really
any system to be resilient beyond its
individual capability there is this
notion of a networked resiliency
and that means you need to understand
how to model the switching in the
distribution systems
and adding those switches as well as how
does damage
due to different events affect those
systems
i think it's fairly open question from a
broader utility perspective
i think there is yet another question
once you have a resiliency model
you need to know what resources are out
there today
in terms of dr from solar panels to
different equipment
and the mapping of this has been lagging
tremendously this data is hard to access
often unavailable in stanford which
started a project called
the stanford energy atlas that uses
satellite imagery
we work with people in machine learning
and so on
and do country-wide mapping of these
resources but there's many such efforts
now
that are happening and i think without
that it's impossible to do
this resiliency assessments excellent
thank you for our next question
would you talk about time resolution of
cloud coordination
what is time resolution then would you
go deeper into that
also could you talk about the
optimization model
and how you deal with changing household
preferences
overall the idea is in the cloud
coordinator itself we run it
five to 15 minutes so when you're
offering ramping services etc but
locally
we run it between a minute and a second
we have tried all of those combinations
the minute seems to be more than enough
the optimization we started with stp
conic optimization to take into account
the network
obviously required a lot of magic to
make it work with like tens of thousands
of homes and large feeders
but recently we moved to the idea of
successive linearization
which despite the absence of strict
performance guarantees
in all of our practical examples and
real feeder systems that we got from
a few utility partners it has done a
really amazing job
and it's super fast super
and i appreciate that insight next
would you talk about what is the
potential for developing
local energy markets distribution
operational markets as distinct from
wholesale market opportunities
and how those distinctive opportunities
can be optimized
if you look not just today
but if you're looking at the same grid
10 years from now for example
you'll have much deeper penetration of
evs
you know particularly uh kind of
delivery vehicles and things like that
that
pull a lot of power and you will need to
start managing the impact of this power
on the distribution network
much more intelligently than today today
there is a big slack capacity on the
distribution system
so we are taking advantage of that if
you go
beyond the united states and look at
other countries for example
in india or in brazil distribution
transformers are often already
overloaded
and adding chargers is kind of a
difficult thing
because there is no benefit for the
flexibility that is
monetized great and for our final
question
there is an interest in understanding
what role universities play
in the pipeline to invent and develop
new technologies
approaches and solutions and then to add
to that
what needs do you have to take the work
that you
and your teams have been doing from
research and initial concepts
to commercialization and adoption i
think that
first and foremost the mission of the
university is education
and i think a gigantic role is preparing
students who can go and address these
challenges
in the real world for all the companies
and policy making and so on out there
there's kind of the set of knowledge the
knowledge base they need to have
to address these problems in future
energy systems is very different from
the past you're not designing
you know transmission lines anymore
you're talking about iot
and communications and distributed
algorithms and things like that but also
policy economics social sciences
so i think that is kind of a first and i
really found a lot of success with the
students at stanford
and at other institutions the second i
think
point that is very critical is the
university can serve
almost like as a neutral zone
where all these different stakeholders
can meet
and exchange ideas exchange information
exchange
data and work together on problems it's
like a neutral ground
because you know the mission is
education and is not for profit
organization
with that mindset we have done a lot of
the projects that you see here
it came out of conversations with the
industry
with very close interactions with them
but with typically with companies that
don't talk to each other
and then also policy makers and so on
and another example of that is at
stanford we have hosted lots of
interesting data sets where we
collaborate in teams
so that the owner of the data set is
aware of all that's going on
but that has led to really useful tools
like wisdom is an example of that
so shared data and i think that the last
piece
and this is something that i think we
need to improve
from the universities is really the
awareness around these problems
i think in the us today you see young
people
much more in tune with the notions and
ideas around sustainability
wanting a 100 renewable grid
but the a deeper understanding of all of
the actual issues
the scale of what this transformation
means and then motivating people
to go and study this get involved and
work in this industry
i think that's something universities
can do certainly a better job of
i think this commercialization side
is often misunderstood because i think
the source of
a lot of the interesting ideas is out of
thinking about
you know the fundamentals and out of
that
it manifests itself sometimes as
software sometimes as just the people
and somebody asked about you know what's
kind of the challenge to
commercialization
having done startups that came out of
stanford in other areas and comparing
them to energy
i think there is two really important
challenges
one is uh energy systems are very
critical
and today they are extremely reliable so
the time scales at which you need to do
a startup are very different
and this actually offers an opportunity
for new types of partnerships
where companies can identify interesting
technologies developed in
stanford or dartmouth and then co-invest
and with the university and there's many
different models that are being explored
to kind of bridge that time scale
there's also programs like the one in
berkeley
the cyclotron road that helps you do
that launch
i think the second challenge and this i
think it's
much more key as a community
in grid we don't really do an excellent
job of keeping
what are kind of important practical
problems
that if addressed there will be a ton of
interest
if you go and you're working with
medical data
or you're thinking about data centers
each one of these communities has it
very clear what are some like target
problems
that can be worked on by companies
researchers and so on
thank you ron for this very informative
and impactful presentation
i want to thank all of you for viewing
this today
as you can see in your screen if you
would like to learn more about the eie
t 237 transforming the grid course
and the other courses offered as part of
the stanford online
energy innovation and emerging
technologies program
you can follow the links on this page
and there are other buttons on the
screen as well
if you found this presentation to be
helpful in any way we encourage you to
share the recording with your colleagues
friends and family or whoever you think
will find this useful
thanks for taking the time to join today
and have a great
rest of your day
you